it's basically the Roman circus again
divide and conquer wild totalitarian
tiptoe siphon the wealth out of both
arguing party slowly while they're
distracted and it's obvious the
United States government got ungodly
bloated there's just been so much
corruption and this ridiculous
gridlock in argument and hatred of the
other meanwhile Global elitists come and
use the United States government as a
piggy bank to just siphon out as much
money from the poor and middle class as
possible exacerbating wealth inequality
inflating the .1% inflating their the
richness meanwhile poor and middle class
people eat dog don't own their own
homes don't own their own time and so
it's it is the Matrix
enslavement and so we are to exit and
build we are to exit and build the new
and we are to obliterate all of
the godamn Matrix tentacles that are
saturating into our spirit